what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things
data data science statistics and
programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
this is going to be the first video in
my julia tutorial series
so in this video i'm going to walk you
through five easy steps
and in those steps we're going to
download the command line version of
julia
then we're going to get set up using
julia which is the main integrated
development environment for julia
we're then going to configure jupiter
notebooks for our julia kernel
that way you have an option you can work
with the atom
text editor for a more r studio or
spider-like integrated development
environment experience
or you can work directly in jupiter
notebooks
at that point it'll be entirely up to
you it'll be largely a matter of
personal preference
but after this tutorial you should be
completely able to work in whatever
environment in julia you want to
now i'm going to be showing you a few
pages on the web here
and naturally the links to all of these
will be provided in the description of
this video
and this particular page here is all the
documentation for juno
again juno is the integrated development
environment for julia that we're going
to be working in
and step number one is the first step
that we're going to do
here that's downloading and installing
julia
so if you click on this hyperlink here
for the downloads page
it's going to take you to this page on
julialang.org
so the current stable release right now
at the time i'm recording this video
is version 1.5.2
so you're going to click on either the
64-bit installer or the 32-bit installer
over here then you're gonna download and
install julia
step two now that you've downloaded and
installed julia is
you want to download and install adam so
if you click on this link
it's going to take you to the website
adam.i
where you can hit this download link and
it's going to download the installer for
you
so just to give a little background on
adam it's a text editor built by github
now juno is an integrated development
environment
that's built on adam so just think of it
like
adam provides you the shell it provides
you a text editor
and then juno is going to sit on top of
that and provide you all the julia
specific enhancements which are going to
make our life so so
easy as you'll see soon here step three
now that you downloaded and installed
adam
go ahead and open adam up then once you
do that it should look
something like this now there's a few
things here which are going to look a
little bit different
for you because i've already installed
juno on my end
but regardless you should get the look
and feel of this pretty quickly
and for those of you who are our
programmers who work in our studio
or python programmers who work in spyder
atoms should look pretty intuitive and
familiar to you
we need to install juno next and we're
going to do this directly from atom
so to do that come up here to file
then go settings then go packages
then from that point you want to look up
in the search bar
uber dash juno
sometimes you need to give it a second
here and it should come up
uber dash juno the official installer of
juno the julia ide
so you're going to see an install button
here and you're going to hit that
so you want to do that and after that's
done
a couple things you need to look for are
look up
julia dash client you need to make sure
that's installed as well
if it's not installed install it and
then
you also want to install this package
ink
go ahead and install all three of these
then restart atom
once you've restarted adam you should
see this juno menu item up here
so that gives you a pretty good idea
that your installation was successful
now one last thing that we want to do
before we're able to write julia code
is you want to go up here to packages
then go to juno
then come all the way down to settings
at that point scroll down just a little
bit here and where it's got julia path
just check and make sure that it's got a
link to your local julia installation
i know that this julia path is my actual
installation
it's got julia 1.5.2 here
i'm ready to go so down here in the
rebel
i'm going to hit enter to start julia
just give it a moment here to get going
and look at that it's starting julia
now that julia has started up we're
going to test it to make sure it works
and obviously we're going to start by
printing hello world
try this and then bam
it returns to you hello world so
you should be able to get to this point
and it should be working for you
now juno is a perfectly wonderful
environment for writing julia code in
but it's absolutely not for everybody
and that's where step four comes in
and that's why we're gonna download and
install anaconda
now those of you especially those who
are python programmers who might already
have anaconda set up
just skip this step but for those of you
totally unfamiliar with anaconda
think of it as one unified platform that
has rstudio on it
it has spider which is a wonderful
python ide
as well as these jupiter frameworks like
jupiter notebooks and jupiter labs
so to set up anaconda you're gonna go to
anaconda's website
make sure you're on the individual
edition you're gonna scroll all the way
down to the bottom
and then you're gonna select your
preferred installer depending on do you
want the 64-bit or the 32-bit
and naturally depending on whether
you're on windows mac or linux
once you've got anaconda installed go
ahead and open up
anaconda navigator just go ahead and
open that up
and you're going to get a page that
looks just like this
so i'm personally going to be working in
jupiter notebook here but it's a very
similar procedure to go through for
jupiter lab
you're going to go over here and you're
going to launch jupiter notebook
once you get jupiter notebook up and
running you're going to get a page that
looks like this
now what this is doing is it's pointing
to
a local drive on your machine and
generally speaking what we're going to
do
is you want to go to new and then you'll
have your
specific installation of julia then you
can just start that notebook up
and do what you need to do using julia
but on your first
time here we need to link julia to
jupiter
now on step five we're gonna go back
into adam here
and we're gonna run our first julia
program so this code is super
straightforward
it's obviously going to be on my github
as well as in the description of this
video
and it's quite straightforward in this
first line of code
we're doing this pkg.ad i julia
thing here now think of this as
completely analogous to like an
install.packages in r
if you're familiar or a pip install from
python
pkg is the internal package manager in
julia
and then i julia is just a julia package
it's the kernel which is going to link
julia
into jupiter so i'm not going to run
this line of code here because i've
already done that
once you've done it once you don't need
to do it again all i'm going to do is
run this using i julia
and notebook part here using i julia is
completely analogous to
a library statement in r or an import
statement from python
we're just going to run this here we're
going to just bring that package into
our environment
and then this notebook statement is
going to launch jupiter
you should get jupiter notebook to pop
back open here
now we're going to go to new and then
you should see your giulio 1.5.2
or whatever your specific version is
here
we're going to open that up
then jupiter notebook is going to come
up here i'm going to test that same
hello world statement here
type that in here and then run it's
thinking about it
and then bam it comes back with hello
world again
so we're all set up with julia in
jupiter notebooks
so this covers getting set up with julia
so now you can write julia code from the
command line
you can write it inside the juno
integrated development environment
or you can write it inside of jupiter
notebook or jupiter lab
so which one of these environments you
decide to use is completely up to you
and your individual preferences but for
the remainder of these tutorials
i'm going to be using jupiter notebooks
so stay tuned for future tutorials
now that you're all set up in julia in
the next tutorial
i'm going to show you how to manipulate
a data set so thanks for watching this
video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it also please take
just half a second to smash the like
button because that really does help me
out
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data